[Musique]
du président américain la Chambre des
communes vendredi très certainement de
la musique aux oreilles de Justin
Trudeau viens faire contrepoint un peu
aux dernières semaines où la question
d'ingérence étrangère à plombée son
gouvernement quel bilan doit-on tirer du
passage de Joe Biden dans la capitale
voyons voir ce qu'on pense mes
collaborateurs
Hébert et chroniqueur au Toronto Star et
au magazine L'actualité Michel
chirurgien politique à La Presse et
Radio-Canada bon dimanche à vous trois
bonjour
Michel il y avait pas mal de monde pas
mal de ministres qui avaient un grand
sourire dans le visage d'une bonne
visite de la semaine dernière pour le
gouvernement Trudeau
oui c'est une bonne visite ils ont eu
de la part du président américain une
coupe de cadeaux et une coupe
d'encouragement aux bons endroits et en
plus ça faisait qu'on avait pas parlé
des étrangères pendant une journée alors
vous mettez tous ensemble oui c'est une
bonne visite et Monsieur Biden n'a rien
demandé du Canada au contraire même ils
étaient en demande des Américains sur le
Canada qui irait être la tête d'une
force multinationale en Haïti
finalement dans la conférence de presse
c'est rendu aux arguments du Canada tant
qu'il y a pas de police nationale soit
le temps d'aller là alors très bonne
journée
deux choses d'abord je vois pas comment
ça aurait pu être du point de vue
canadien du point de vue du gouvernement
libéral une meilleure visite qui tombait
à point nommé pour le gouvernement on
s'en doute parce que ça donne
Justin Trudeau l'occasion de recadrer
son gouvernement ce dont il a bien
besoin recadrer parce que la semaine
prochaine mardi donc ça va être le
budget on verra si le premier ministre
le gouvernement avec le budget réussi à
continuer sur cette lancée là mais c'est
à cette avantage là et je dirais au-delà
de ça que Joe Biden dans son discours et
de la façon dont il l'a présenté les
objectifs l'économie nord-américaine
offert un cadre différent de la relation
économique Canada c'est-à-dire pas
seulement on n'est pas seulement au
tildi en train de jouer défense on se
protège du protectionnisme américain lui
présentait ça
oui c'est incontestablement la grande
victoire j'étais de ceux et nous étions
nombreux
annonces et pourtant ce fut le cas on se
demandait ce que Baby n'a exigé quelque
chose en échange on n'a pas trouvé dans
le communiqué ou dans les déclarations
quoi que ce soit dans ce sens-là donc
c'est une victoire nette ça veut pas
dire que le problème de l'immigration
irrégulaire est réglé et comprenons-nous
il peut y avoir des conséquences
importantes à ce qu'on applique
l'entendre sur les tiers à la grandeur
de la frontière est-ce qu'il y aura plus
de clandestins en forêt dans toutes
sortes de points d'entrées réguliers
plutôt que de concentrer tout ça Roxane
mais c'était devenu un symbole important
et à court terme c'est certainement un
gain politique pour Justin Trudeau c'est
difficile de voir à quel dans quoi le
Canada aurait perdu quelque chose dans
cette visite là même le fameux presque
passage obligé ou un président américain
nous rappelle qu'on dépense pas 2% de
notre PIB en matière de défense même ça
que Barack Obama avait pourtant soulevé
lui la dernière fois
même ça ça a pas apparu dans le discours
de Joe Biden peut-être que on trouvait
ça une approprié avec la contribution du
Canada en Ukraine qui est quand même
assez importante par rapport à notre
poids géographique et diplomatique mais
même ça ça a pas apparu nulle part on a
parlé de du fait que le Canada avait des
ressources naturelles on pouvait donc
plus jouer un rôle dans la transition
énergétique dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement des véhicules
électriques bref à peu près tout y était
pour que le Canada dise c'est vraiment
une très bonne visite alors oui
difficile de trouver quelque chose à
vrai dire
les demandes qu'on n'a pas entendu en
public par rapport à Obama en faut
s'entendre Obama en fin de mandat et en
fin de course et d'autre part Justin
Trudeau venait d'arriver donc quand le
président Obama était venu dire qu'on a
besoin de plus de Canada dans le temps
et à la limite qui pouvait être en train
de parler du gouvernement conservateur
précédent celui qui venait de quitter le
pouvoir plutôt que du gouvernement
Justin Trudeau la réponse aux demandes
sur la défense s'il y en a une et s'il y
a eu des demandes en privé il faudra
voir ça dans le budget Freeland mardi
parce que c'est là que ça va ou pas ce
se présenter ce Roxane
politiquement à court terme c'est sûr
que François Legault fait un point de
presse et qu'il dit dans son point de
pêche merci Monsieur Trudeau c'est quand
même un moment il faut garder il faut
garder l'enregistrement et si on est
il va y avoir d'abord la Cour suprême
qui va se prononcer sur la valeur ou pas
légal de l'entente sur le tiers pays sûr
on ne sait pas dans quel sens ça va
aller ce jugement là ça se pourrait que
dans trois mois l'entente existe plus
dépendant de la décision surtout
l'auteur ça va être qu'en hiver va
arriver
s'il y a des gens qui s'aventurent dans
des endroits beaucoup moins sécuritaires
et que ça finit comme c'est totalement
possible plutôt mal
il y a quelque chose quelque part qui
dit que l'opinion publique canadienne
risque de se retourner contre l'Entente
qui s'applique maintenant l'ensemble de
la frontière qu'on célèbre aujourd'hui
il y a deux dossiers qui ont été
soulevés entre autres par Monsieur
polliève la question du bois d'oeuvre
qui a pas été réglé la question du by
American qui a pas été réglé non plus
est-ce que est-ce que on s'attendait à
faire des avancées ce que ce que ça
c'est une déception pour le gouvernement
Trudeau
je pense pas le bois d'oeuvre on en
parle on en parle depuis bien avant que
nous croyons comme nous casser dans le
journaliste et
le bail américain fait cette année 190E
anniversaire on est un peu habitué à le
voir dans le chemin là c'est sûr que les
chambres de commerce certaines provinces
le goût dit ça on aimerait ça être
intégré au by American sauf qu'on se
fait pas intégrer dans la loi d'un autre
pays comme ça d'une part et qu'est-ce
que là il va falloir se poser la
question qu'est-ce que le Canada va
donner en retour alors c'est peut-être
dire on n'a pas réglé le by américain
c'était pas quelque chose qui va arriver
de ciseaux et prend peut-être pas de
notre vie alors faut faut tempérer ça
c'est une demande des milieux d'affaires
constantes mais il y a quelques il y a
une telle chose la souveraineté des pays
ça c'était la visite de Monsieur byden
jeudi vendredi la veille on parlait
encore d'ingérence étrangère d'ingérence
chinoise dans le processus électoral
canadien avec la déception ou la
démission d'un député libéral qui est le
caucus en fait suite de l'élégation qui
a été publiée par globonos je vous faire
écouter la façon dont le député en
question a démissionné à la Chambre des
communes et on revient là-dessus tout de
suite après
[Musique]
l'objet de délégation dans un article de
global qui laisse entendre des documents
des services secrets qu'ils auraient
consulté que grâce en tant qu'il aurait
demandé à la consul du gouvernement
chinois Toronto de retarder la
libération des deux Michael
on comprend que c'est une histoire qui
est assez complexe bon d'abord je pense
que bien fait de quitter le cocus
libéral il y aurait été une distraction
puis je pense qu'il le savait lui-même
que le temps qu'il éclaircissement de
son rôle il soit mieux de quitter donc
ce que vous avez vu l'un était le geste
à poser très émotif mais le juste le bon
geste à poser maintenant qu'est-ce que
vraiment été dit au consul Toronto de la
Chine en février 2021 global deux
sources qui disent que Monsieur Dog a
incité la Chine à retarder la libération
des deux MacOS qui était
qui était là depuis déjà deux ans en
prison en Chine parce que sous prétexte
que ça favoriserait le Parti
conservateur sur les relâcher plutôt
ça c'est le bout qui est le plus
difficile à comprendre d'abord qu'un
député soit complètement à l'inverse la
position de leur propre de son propre
parti puis ensuite que ça avantage d'une
quelconque façon les conservateurs
souvenez-vous quand les deux Michaels
ont été relâchés tout juste avant la
campagne électorale finalement quelques
mois plus tard il y a personne qui est
dit mon dieu c'est un jour sombre pour
Justin Trudeau un grand jour pour la
partie conservateur plutôt été tant que
ça finisse puis c'est une victoire
clairement pour les libéraux qu'on soit
capable de régler ça avant la campagne
électorale donc pourquoi à moins que le
monsieur donne une liste très très mal
le paysage politique canadien qui soit
pas du tout capable de savoir qui
pourquoi profite à qui ça c'est le bout
du casse-tête qui est en plein milieu
c'est le gros morceau en plein milieu du
cancer qui ne va nulle part et c'est ce
qui nous fait poser des questions sur
l'histoire de Monsieur dogue en
particulier
Chantal puis Michel ensuite
il faut s'entendre il y a pas de preuve
de tout ça il s'agit de la négation là
mais Chantal d'abord
il y a malaise ce sont des sources
anonymes qui
dans les renseignements ont pas été
jugés assez solide par le globalement
qui est important à faire
ses repas de ces histoires là et
pourquoi le globalement pas touché à
l'histoire parce qu'ils ont pas eu accès
à la transcription des échanges sur
lesquels tout certes échafaudages là
s'appuient alors il y a déjà un certain
malaise journalistique là-dessus ensuite
écoutez
il voit on va savoir plutôt que tard où
on devrait savoir plutôt que tard si
Monsieur donne est traité justement et
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que ça
donne tout de même une soudaine utilité
au mandat de Davy Johnston le rapporteur
spécial du gouvernement qui lui a accès
et a le droit d'avoir accès à l'ensemble
de la preuve
donc avant même d'être obligé de dire ça
prend une enquête publique ou pas et
d'attendre toute cette enquête publique
monsieur Johnson peut dire j'ai pas vu
dans tout ça quelque chose qui met en
cause monsieur donne de cette façon-là
c'est vrai aussi du comité de
parlementaire sur la sécurité nationale
qui eux aussi ont accès à tous les
documents alors en gros un il faut
espérer pour le bien global qu'ils
étaient sur du terrain solide et deux on
devrait normalement être capable de le
savoir plutôt que tard et avant même la
conclusion d'une enquête publique si il
doit y avoir ce genre d'enquête Michel
est-ce que ça ça vient ça vient rendre
la tenue d'une enquête publique de moins
en moins ou de plus en plus inévitable
cela dit il va falloir aussi que dans
laquelle publique on fasse la part des
choses sur ce que font nos agences de
l'enseignement les renseignements qui
choisissent de rendre public ou de
laisser filer à la presse parce que on
n'a pas une histoire particulièrement
brillante au Canada sur la façon dont
nos agences de renseignements font un
travail souvenez-vous de l'insurrection
appréhendée en octobre 70 ma première
affectation comme journaliste c'était de
couvrir la commission cap qui vont les
services de renseignement dire et redire
devant le juge toutes les fausses clés
qu'ils avaient dites à l'époque la GRC
qui avait qui avait posé des gens qui
avaient fait brûler une grange je peux
vous en donner jusqu'à demain matin
alors de toute façon ce qui se passe au
service de l'enseignement on prend ça
avec des pincettes on fait bien
attention puis c'est pas parce que deux
agents sont ouverts la trappe que ça
devient la vérité
d'abord on a même pas besoin de remonter
jusqu'aux années 70 là l'histoire de ma
mère et la commission c'est penché
là-dessus et qui a trouvé quoi qu'on
avait fait des fuites quand on s'était
aperçu qu'on avait fourni des fours
renseignements au service de sécurité
américaine qui s'en sont servis pour
déporter ma mère alors vers la série où
il a été détenu et torturé à la place de
dire on s'est trompé ils ont envoyé des
fours renseignements et on fait des
fuites aux médias pour se donner une
belle image et le juge que cette enquête
même écrit que la GRC avait donné des
séances de greffage au Conseil privé et
ça c'est le ministère du Premier
ministre où on avait omis des faits qui
pourraient faire mal paraître la GRC
alors excusez-moi là mais ça ça s'est
passé après l'an 2000 dans ce siècle si
premièrement deuxièmement ça c'est une
note au sujet de la visite Biden
qui refait la boucle si Michael Poirier
sont convaincus que le gouvernement du
Canada a joué avec leur liberté pour des
saints politique ça paraissait pas
vendredi alors qu'ils étaient traités en
héros aux communes et ensuite au souper
d'État oui parce qu'ils étaient aux
communes et
occuper des temps c'est tout le temps
qu'il nous reste malheureusement Alex
Chantal Michel excellente semaine on se
parle la semaine prochaine on va parler
de budget à ce moment-là